alcohol has been with us since 10,000 BC
the ancient Egyptians had 17 types of
beer and 24 varieties of wine in fact
beer was a dietary staple long before
bread or what exactly is alcohol alcohol
is what we call a special group of
chemicals ethanol is the only drinkable
alcohol ethanol is what you drink on a
Friday night but other types of alcohol
include methanol and isopropanol however
I would highly recommend against
drinking these they are used in many
different fields including medical the
human body constantly produces small
amounts of alcohol itself alcohol is a
drug a depressant to be precise however
in small doses it can act as a stimulant
it's only when you consume too much that
it's depressant effects kicks in and you
end up feeling like this alcohol slows
your vital functions causing slurred
speech unsteady movement and inability
to react quickly and generally bad
decisions but why do we get a hangover
when we drink too much
well hangovers are pretty damn nasty but
what do you expect
alcohol is essentially a poison I'm sure
you're already well aware but let me
remind you of the symptoms of a hangover
dehydration
dry mouth tiredness headache nausea
weakness anxiety irritability pessimism
reduced concentration sensitivity to
light and noise trouble sleeping and
generally a feeling I've taught to me
and you'll regret it but what is it
about alcohol that causes these symptoms
the biggest factor is dehydration
alcohol is a diuretic this means you pee
more and dehydrate very fast this is
exactly the reason you get a headache
whilst dehydrated your body takes water
from your brain to give to other parts
of your body causing your brain to
literally shrink and
that can be very painful alcohol is
produced through the process of
fermentation where various foods are
fermented with yeast during this process
these converts mulch sugars into alcohol
beer is made up of four basic
ingredients barley wheat hops and yeast
what the process of winemaking is a bit
more complicated firstly the grapes are
picked and hand sorted to remove things
like sticks and rocks the grapes are
then crushed and distend they are their
mixed reviews various nutrients and acid
the mixture is then fermented for a
couple of weeks a device called a
hydrometer is used to measure the
alcohol verse sugar levels and determine
when the wine is just right the mixture
is then put into a big press and you
guessed it pressed the resulting liquid
is collected oak chips are added for
flavor and the wine is left to sit for
months and months during this time the
wine is transferred from bottle to
bottle until the liquid is completely
clear Campton tablets are then added
this kills bacteria and stops any
further fermentation the wine is them
bottled sealed with a cork or a screw
top and left to age for years until it
is finally consumed if a wine has
co-opted it has reacted with the cork
and spoiled inside the bottle the
world's biggest consumer of alcohol per
person is the Czech Republic drinking at
an astonishing 15 liters of alcohol per
person per year in fact as a continent
Europe is by far the world's biggest
alcohol consumer the top 13 countries
for getting pissed of all European
shamefully the United Kingdom is only
15th on this list guzzling down 11.7
litres of alcohol per person every year
way ahead of the United States it's only
8.5 liters per person in most countries
the legal drinking age is 18 only 12
countries have a drinking age above 18
and there are 19 countries where there's
absolutely no legal drinking games at
all internationally the average age when
a person first tastes an alcoholic
beverage is 12 and shockingly well than
80 percent of people are regular
drinkers by age 15 in small amount
whole can have health benefits on your
heart although there are countless
harmful effects on the body when drunk
regularly in large quantities but
alcohol is fun and can leave you with
many good memories or none at all so go
out and enjoy yourself just don't overdo
it